so everyone was like oh but meryl streep
is there for let's serve up some news
sunny side up
it's don't look up
it's the
juggernaut directed by adam mckay it has
jennifer lawrence leonardo dicaprio
meryl streep jonah hill
it is all the rage and they're on the
press circuit right now and i found out
a really fun fact that i wanted to share
with you
pop sugar reports that apparently jonah
got in trouble
for bringing along a fart machine what
um
i like already love jonah but this makes
me love him a lot more so everyone was
like oh but meryl streep is there for us
of course she's there for and jonah you
are a hero for the fart community thank
you for standing up
i there's nothing funnier i'm sorry
until i'm 90 years old nothing will be
funnier than a farmer
and someone has to toot their own tutor
good for you
well apparently netflix has formally
asked jonah to maybe stop with the farts
but jonah said that he will not stop
with the farts
hollywood reporter reports that they
have picked the man to bring him to life
it is none other than british actor tom
holland come on
um
you know him as spider-man but he
started his career dancing in billy
elliot in london's west end
and um amazon's also making their own
fred and ginger movie starring jamie
bell who was originally billy elliot in
the film and margaret quality who is
literally one of my favorite human
beings on the planet andy mcdowell's
daughter a total revelation
first up we're going to beautiful
lake como shall we everybody oh yes
italy where they shot the high fashion
movie of the season house of gucci
villa balbiano was the actual home of
the gucci patriarch aldo gucci
and now vogue reports that you can rent
it on airbnb say what i know
they're offering one lucky guest the
chance to stay for a night for the price
of one thousand one hundred and thirty
three dollars check out these photos it
was built in the late 16th century
hosted wild society parties in the 17th
century and today it's decked out with
antique furnishings and art fought at
sotheby's
why one person ross why couldn't you get
like a group to like split the bill and
party that house is so big yeah raw
thoughts yeah i did the math right so 1
133
if you get a group of 10 people divide
it carry the one that's 113 and 30 cents
a person okay
and i'll tell you
if you are like a house of gucci kind of
person on a house of tj maxx budget
that's what you got to do and that's how
i kick it
allure magazine is reporting that this
renaissance woman has revealed that she
has yet another talent oh she just does
uh tattoos oh oh in her spare time in
her spare time apparently dakota gave
olivia coleman her very first tattoo
using a stick and poke kit oh what is
that now a stick and poke it's like you
dip it in the ink and then you jam it in
the skin
uh
don't get any ideas barry moore that's
not happening
no you know what i would do to you like
the toothpaste on the finger and put
your hand in the hot water like real
can't 80s camp movie stuff oh yeah but
this you got a tattoo here on the show
you remember i certainly did get a
tattoo here on the show
right there it says home is where we are
and there's another one under it that
says please god moisturize my skin
um well we don't know what her tattoo is
or where it is
but we do know that it happened after a
wild night celebrating their new movie
the lost daughter directed by maggie
gyllenhaal food and wine reports a live
streamer in china known as mr kang is no
longer welcome at haddandi seafood and
barbecue buffet because he eats too much
the restaurant owner says he loses money
every time mr king walks in the door so
how much food are we talking here one
time he ate eight pounds of prawn which
is approximately 300 prawns by our rough
prawn math you know prawn math it's
sweeping the nation
i mean
all you can eat is a dare
what do you think rossi well i well let
me
listen to me sir i will represent you in
court pro bono okay
all you can eat means all you can eat
okay i will approach the bench for you
this i
tell my dying day i will fight for this
buffets mean buffet for a reason you
understand so
don't comment me don't tell me
oh you know it gets me heated i never
get this upset about this but you tell
me all i can eat challenge accepted
[Music]